Масмедіа бомбардують нас інформацією зі світу моди, примушуючи купувати дедалі новіший одяг.
А старий - просто викидати, коли він виходить з моди.
Приблизно 93 мільйони тонн одягу викидається на сміттєзвалища або спалюється щороку.
Близько однієї вантажівки текстилю щосекунди йде на сміттєзвалища. Щосекунди!
Виробництво одягу також забруднює нашу воду та додає викидів CO2.
Модель швидкої моди, запроваджена Zara, означає, що бренди нині випускають удвічі більше одягу на рік, ніж ще на початку 2000-их.
Самі компанії запевняють, що ситуація змінюється, адже тепер ми можемо купувати екологічну швидку моду! Однак чи можна їм довіряти?
Дві найбільші у світі торгові мережі модного одягу - Inditex, материнська компанія Zara, та H&M -
випускають колекції, виготовлені, як вони стверджують, із меншою шкодою для довкілля.
Нумо, перевіримо ці обіцянки! Почнімо з матеріалів!
Основними матеріалами у Zara та H&M, як і у всьому світі, є поліестер та бавовна.
Частка поліестру у загальному виробництві волокна - 52%, бавовни - близько 24%.
ПЕТ - це просто інша назва поліестру і це той самий вид пластику, що й у пляшках для води.  Виробляється цей матеріал з нафти.
Його виробництво вимагає великих витрат енергії та зумовлює багато викидів CO2, водночас у воду потрапляють кислоти та аміак.
З бавовною таких проблем немає, але її виробництво вимагає надзвичайно багато води та застосування хімікатів.
За даними Фонду дикої природи, для виробництва одного кілограма бавовни потрібно 20 тисяч літрів води.
Також близько 11 відсотків усіх пестицидів використовують на бавовняних полях.
У довгостроковій перспективі органічна бавовна набагато краща для фермера, який її вирощує, для довкілля і для ґрунту, на якому вона росте.
Вона потребує  менше води і не вимагає рясного зрошення як такого.
Дати нам інтерв'ю H&M відмовились.
У Zara також відповіли лише електронною поштою:
Але "екологічна" не означає "органічна". H&M заявляє, що екологічна бавовна - це отримана з вторсировини або бавовна,
на виробництво якої використано менше пестицидів та ГМО.
Zara свою екологічну бавовну називає не "органічною", а "екологічно вирощеною".
Мовляв, у виробництві використовуються натуральні добрива та пестициди.
Також вона має сертифікати "Стандарт органічного змісту" та "Глобальний стандарт органічного текстилю ",
які засвідчують контроль використання хімікатів та води в усьому виробничому процесі.
Терміни "свідомий" та "екологічно вирощений" важко перевірити, вони лише вводять в оману споживача.
Але, за даними громадської організації "Біржа текстилю", у 2016 році H&M була другим за величиною споживачем органічної бавовни у світі.
Zara була на четвертому місці. Перейдемо до синтетики.
У так званій "екологічній" колекції синтетичного одягу від H&M щонайменше 50 відсотків повинні бути з перероблених матеріалів.
Zara не вказує конкретний відсоток, і маркування на її одязі не зовсім зрозуміле.
У цій куртці вказано, що це 100% перероблений поліамід, що створює враження, наче він повністю з вторсировини.
Але наповнювач - поліестер. Це інший матеріал. І це не подинокий випадок.
Заява про відсоток переробленої продукції часто не стосується всього одягу, тому виглядає так, ніби виріб більш екологічний, ніж це є насправді.
Zara взяла на себе зобов'язання повністю перейти на екологічні бавовну та поліестер до 2025 року.
H&M заявляє, що всі їхні матеріали будуть екологічними до 2030 року.
Якщо компанії дотримаються цих зобов'язань, це може означати великі зміни для галузі.
Але матеріал – лише частина проблеми.
Щоб з'ясувати, чи є ця бавовна справді органічною і чи поліестер дійсно перероблений, споживачі повинні мати можливість
перевірити сам виробничий процес. З даних на футболці H&M Conscious – "свідомої" колекції - ви можете дізнатись,
на якому конкретному заводі вона виготовлена, тому  теоретично можна перевірити екологічність заводу.
Zara натомість перелічує лише кількість постачальників в одному місті, але не їхні назви та адреси.
Їх обох оцінила Fashion Revolution - організація, яка виступає за прозорість та екологічність у моді.
Жоден з 250 великих брендів не набрав понад 80% балів.
Найвищий рейтинг прозорості мала H&M - 73%. Zara набрала 43%.
Постачальники - одні з небагатьох, хто знає процес виробництва зсередини.
Кім була керівницею швейної фабрики в Камбоджі.
Вони мають унікальний доступ до інформації, яка потрібна споживачам, аби ті могли перевіряти, чи співпадають дії брендів з їхніми словами.
Якби була можливість перевіряти постачальників, можна було б притягати виробників моди до відповідальності.
Прозорий ще не означає екологічний. Це зовсім цього не означає. І це справді дуже важливо.
Навіть брендам, які знають весь свій ланцюжок поставок, важко виробляти екологічно чистий одяг.
Давайте візьмемо денім. Бачите, фарбування здійснюється більш екологічно відповідально,
але це не стосується виробництва бавовни.
У рекламі H&M сказано, що компанія працює над циркуляцією одягу в майбутньому.
За даними веб-сайту, ви можете принести свій одяг у будь-який магазин, і він буде перепроданий як секонд-хенд або перероблений.
У Zara є аналогічна рекламна кампанія. Що ж відбувається?
Речі справді перепродають, повторно використовують та переробляють.
Але не у тих пропорціях, як ви гадаєте. Більше половини подарованого одягу продається за кордоном.
Решта переважно перетворюється на промисловий матеріал, спалюється або йде на звалище.
H&M та Zara вкладають гроші у дослідження ресайклінгу.
Але ми поглянули на їхні річні звіти, і з'ясували: в однієї це 0,5 відсотка від прибутків, у другої - нуль цілих дві сотих відсотка.
Одяг, що циркулює. Це ще одна неправда. І навіть якби так було насправді...
Це не компенсує наше надмірне споживання. Чи наше надмірне виробництво.
Проблема полягає в тому, що виробляється і купується занадто багато одягу.
Нам потрібно переосмислити те, як ми робимо покупки і до чого насправді закликаємо.
Низка відомих брендів та будинків моди зробили значний крок.
Вони стають безсезонними. Це варто поваги. І це важливий внесок.
Цей підхід не означає пожертвувати модою. Йдеться про те, щоб одяг носився довше, а не викидався.
H&M та Zara заявляють, що їхні екологічні колекції є кращими для довкілля. І це насправді так.
Якщо ви хочете бути певні у тому, що модна річ, яку ви купуєте, створювалась цілком екологічно, то краще звернути увагу на безліч менших брендів.
Вони дозволяють перевірити кожен крок свого виробничого процесу.
А придбання безсезонного замість модного одягу означає, що він не вийде з моди і не потрапить у сміття.
Адже мода - та галузь, на яку споживачі мають реальний вплив.
Коли я дивлюсь на картину в цілому, я усвідомлюю, що, можливо, лише кінцеві споживачі є тією силою,
яка може збалансувати бренди і підштовхнути їх, натиснути на них задля певних змін.
Отже, цікавтеся не тільки тим, хто виготовив ваш одяг і з чого він зроблений,
запитайте себе, чи потрібен вам цей новий одяг?